This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vitaantham. We like stories about leaders who have big ideas, who define the odds and pursue their goals with messianic purpose. Think of Winston Churchill in World War II, or Abraham Lincoln during the Civil War. But what happens when a leader's vision is the wrong one? How do we think about people who dream big, only to invite disaster?
这里是《隐藏的脑》，我是香卡·维塔安塔姆。我们喜欢关于那些胸怀大志、无视命运并带着救世主般的目标追求理想的领袖的故事。想想二战时的温斯顿·丘吉尔，或者内战时期的亚伯拉罕·林肯。但当一个领袖的愿景是错误的时候会发生什么？我们该如何看待那些心怀宏大梦想却最终招致灾难的人？
At such times, we might prefer a more cautious style, someone who plays the odds. Those leaders might not score historic triumphs, but they rarely cause catastrophes. Thousands of years ago, the Greek poet Archylicus summed up this idea. He said, the fox knows many things, but the hedgehog knows one big thing. That has been, that parable has been the subject of much debate over the last 2,500 years. What exactly are killika's meant? This is a psychologist Phil Tetlock.
在这样的时刻，我们可能会更喜欢一种谨慎的风格，也就是那种权衡利弊的人。这些领袖或许不会取得历史性的功绩，但他们很少酿成灾难。几千年前，希腊诗人阿基洛科斯总结了这个观点。他说，狐狸知道许多事，但刺猬知道一件大事。在过去的2500年里，这个寓言一直是许多争论的主题。基利卡（注：此处为识别错误，实指阿基洛科斯 Archilochus）究竟是什么意思？这是心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克。
Various people have offered various interpretations. Some people coming out on the side of the hedgehog, saying the hedgehog will trump the fox, and other people saying no, it really means the fox is going to do better. There are different ways to think about the metaphor, but here's how I see it. If a fox wants dinner, it has many options. It can chase down a hedgehog, it can find something else to eat. It can even go without food for a day. But if you're a hedgehog being chased by a fox, you don't have multiple goals. You have
不同的人提出了不同的解释。有些人站在刺猬这一边，认为刺猬会胜过狐狸，而另一些人则说不，这实际上意味着狐狸会做得更好。思考这个隐喻有不同的方法，但我是这样看的。如果一只狐狸想要吃晚餐，它有很多选择。它可以追捕一只刺猬，可以找到其他东西吃。它甚至可以一天不吃东西。但如果你是一只被狐狸追赶的刺猬，你就不会有多个目标。你有
one overarching idea. Don't get eaten. Tatlok thinks this metaphor also describes two cognitive styles in people. Foxes have different strategies for different problems. They are comfortable with nuance. They can live with contradictions. Hejog's focus on the big picture. They see every problem through the lens of a single organizing principle. The Hejogs are more parsimonious, more decisive. In most MBA programs,, they probably viewed as better leadership material. This week on Hidden Brain, we have the story of a hedgehog, a surgeon who changed the
一个首要的想法。不要被吃掉。泰特洛克认为这个隐喻也描述了人类的两种认知风格。狐狸对不同的问题有不同的策略。它们对细微差别感到自在。它们能与矛盾共存。刺猬专注于宏观大局。它们透过单一组织原则的镜头来看待每一个问题。刺猬更加简练、更加果断。在大多数MBA项目中，他们可能被视为更好的领导材料。本周的《隐藏网》（注：即 Hidden Brain），我们将讲述一个刺猬的故事，一个以大胆方式改变了
world in daring ways. His bold style made him a pioneer in what is today become the transgender movement. It also propelled him to create one of the world's first international medical missions. Like other hedgehogs, this surgeon experienced outside success until one day he didn't. It's just that God damn disaster, an awful thing. Greatness and tragedy, this week on Hidden Brain. This week on Hidden Brain. Sandy Stone was born in 1936 in the midst of the Great Depression. Her parents gave her a Hebrew name. It was there like Ben Nautan.
世界的外科医生的故事。他大胆的风格使他成为如今已成为跨性别运动的先驱。这也促使他创建了世界上最早的国际医疗任务之一。像其他刺猬一样，这位外科医生体验到了局外的成功，直到有一天他不再成功。这就是那该死的灾难，一件可怕的事。伟大与悲剧，本周《隐藏的脑》。本周《隐藏的脑》。桑迪·斯通于1936年大萧条时期出生。她的父母给她起了一个希伯来名字。那是泽利格·本·纳坦。
Zellig Ben Nautan, a boy's name. That's because her parents thought she was a boy. But from a very early age, she knew she was a girl. This was a long time ago, decades before the modern trans movement. When Sandy was a child, there were no words, no language, to describe what she knew about herself. It was lonely, it was disorienting, it was puzzling, confusing, scary, it was all of those things. It stayed like that for Sandy all the way into adulthood. She went to school, became a recording engineer, moved to the Bay Area.
泽利格·本·纳坦，一个男孩的名字。那是因为她的父母以为她是个男孩。但从很小的时候起，她就知道自己是个女孩。这很久以前了，比现代跨性别运动早了几十年。当桑迪还是个孩子的时候，没有任何词汇、没有任何语言来描述她对自己的认知。那是孤独的、迷失方向的、令人困惑的、令人害怕的，所有这些感觉都有。桑迪就这样一直保持到成年。她去上学，成了一名录音工程师，搬到了湾区。
All the while, everyone thought she was a man. She kept searching for help. In the San Francisco phone book she found a promising lead. It was a group for gay men. When she called, they asked if she was gay. She said she wasn't. So they sent her away and told her to try another group. The outfit they recommended surprised Sandy. It was the San Francisco Police Department. It turned out that the police department was running a counseling unit of sorts, which they did for the population of transgender people that lived in the San Francisco tenderloin, which was sort of the
一直以来，每个人都以为她是个男人。她一直在寻求帮助。在旧金山电话簿里，她找到了一个有希望的线索。那是一个同性恋男性的组织。当她打电话时，他们问她是不是同性恋。她说她不是。于是他们把她打发走了，告诉她去试试别的组织。他们推荐的机构让桑迪大吃一惊。那是旧金山警察局。原来警察局运营着某种咨询部门，他们为住在旧金山田德隆区的跨性别群体提供这种服务，那片区域有点像是
down and outskid row section of town that tended to collect people who couldn't afford to live anywhere else or who had run out of options. Trans people who ended up in the tenderloin were at high risk for drug addiction and prostitution. They were social outcasts. When Sandy got in touch with the police to ask for help, the first thing they did was to dissuade her from acting on her feelings.
城里潦倒的贫民窟地段，往往聚集着那些住不起其他地方或走投无路的人。最终流落到田德隆区的跨性别者面临着很高的药物成瘾和卖淫风险。他们是社会的边缘人。当桑迪联系警方寻求帮助时，他们做的第一件事就是劝阻她不要根据自己的感觉行事。
And they actually tried to discourage me by taking on a tour that reminded me of Dante being led down into the lower circles of hell. They really showed me the worst of everything and then said, are you sure you still want to go ahead with what you were thinking of? And to be perfectly honest, I wasn't quite sure what you were thinking of. And to be perfectly honest, I was not quite sure what I was thinking of. I was just trying to collect information.
他们实际上试图通过带我参观来打消我的念头，这让我想起了但丁被引导进入地狱的下层。他们真的向我展示了所有糟糕的事情，然后说，你确定你还要继续你想做的事吗？说实话，我不太确定你在想什么。说实话，我不太确定我在想什么。我只是在试图收集信息。
And I think it would be safe to say that that's what we were all doing at that time. Still, the referral to the police turned out to be a stroke of luck. The cops told her that a center at Stanford University had recently started performing what were then called sex change operations. They didn't refer me to Stanford as much as talk about it, as the great unethaneable
我想可以肯定地说，这就是我们当时都在做的事情。不过，警方的推荐结果证明是一次幸运的巧合。警察告诉她，斯坦福大学的一个中心最近开始进行当时被称为变性手术的手术。与其说他们把我推荐给斯坦福，不如说是在谈论它，把它当作伟大的、不可企及的
goal, the great beautiful shining star in the sky. After years of suffering and loneliness and confusion, the Stanford program felt like a beacon. Sandy felt she might finally have a chance to live a more honest, satisfying life. But first, she had to convince the gatekeeper, who stood between her and the person she wanted to become. He ran what was then called the Gender Disphoria Program at Stanford. His name was Don Lob.
目标，天空中伟大而美丽的闪亮之星。经历了多年的痛苦、孤独和困惑后，斯坦福的项目感觉像是一座灯塔。桑迪觉得她终于有机会过上更诚实、更满意的生活。但首先，她必须说服那个站在她和她想成为的人之间的守门人。他负责管理斯坦福当时所谓的性别烦躁项目。他的名字叫唐·洛布。
The gatekeeper of Stanford's Gender Disphoria Program was a hedgehog. From a very early age, he had a big picture right there. He wanted to help people. He wanted to help a lot of people. As a small child, when kids in his school were asked to donate money to a charity, his classmates contributed a dime. Don worked in a vegetable garden an entire summer to raise a whopping $10. Now, I got a letter, a preserved letter from it that my mother wrote to some of her friends saying, Don, he's done something and nobody has ever done.
斯坦福性别烦躁项目的守门人是一只刺猬。从很小的时候起，他就有一个宏大的宏观画面。他想帮助人们。他想帮助很多人。作为一个小孩子，当他学校里的孩子被要求向慈善机构捐款时，他的同学捐了一毛钱。唐在一个菜园里干了一整个夏天，筹集了高达10美元的巨款。现在，我收到了一封信，一封保存下来的信，是我母亲写给她的一些朋友的，上面说，唐，他做了一件从来没有人做过的事。
Don's father feared his little boy was consumed with being a do-gooder, that he would turn out to be a failure at business. His father was right. Don Lob became a doctor. When he came to Stanford in the 1960s, he was a young, ambitious plastic surgeon, very much in awe of his prize winning colleagues. Coming to Stanford, I was overshadowed by the hugeness of what people were doing, the importance of it.
唐的父亲担心他的小男孩一心只想做好事，将来会在商业上失败。他的父亲是对的。唐·洛布成为了一名医生。当他在20世纪60年代来到斯坦福时，他是一个年轻、雄心勃勃的整形外科医生，对他的获奖同事们非常敬畏。来到斯坦福，我被人们正在做的事情的宏大和重要性所掩盖。
So I knew that I had to do something, right? Maybe, you know, I gotta do this, somewhere along the line because everybody else here is doing it. Don was looking for a place to make his mark. One day, a colleague walked out of an examination room and came up to him. When I said, Don, I'm watching you to see a patient.
所以我知道我必须做点什么，对吧？也许，你知道，我必须在某个时候做这件事，因为这里的每个人都在这样做。唐在寻找一个能留下自己印记的地方。有一天，一位同事从检查室走出来，走向他。当我走过去时，唐，我正带你看一个病人。
It's a good case. You might not like it. It's a sex change. Remember, this was 1968. I said, Dave, send that patient away. I'm a Catholic boy from the Midwest and I'm at Stanford. We don't do those things. But Dan's colleague insisted he meet the patient. To be clear, this patient was not Sandy Stone. He said, do me a favor and go in that room. I went in the room and talked to the patient and I said,
这是一个不错的病例。你可能不会喜欢。这是一个变性手术。记住，那是1968年。我说，戴夫，把那个病人打发走吧。我是一个来自中西部的天主教男孩，我在斯坦福。我们不做那些事。但丹的同事坚持要他去见见那个病人。需要说明的是，这个病人不是桑迪·斯通。他说，帮个忙，进那个房间去。我走进房间和病人谈了谈，我说，
now why do you want to section? She said, well, I was born and this is what I should be. I said, well, when did you decide that she said, I didn't decide it? This is what I was born with from day one. This patient was a pioneer. No one on the west coast had received what's come to be done today as gender reassignment surgery or gender confirmation surgery.
现在你为什么要做切除手术？她说，嗯，我出生时就是这样，这正是我应该成为的样子。我说，好吧，你是什么时候决定这样的？她说，我没有决定。这就是我从第一天起生来就有的。这个病人是一位先驱。西海岸没有人接受过今天被称为性别重置手术或性别确认手术的治疗。
In fact, the surgery had been rarely performed across the whole world. Don was an unlikely choice of doctor. He was, by his own account, a prim man from the Midwest. But although Dawn initially blanched the idea of gender reassignment surgery, he felt a shiver of excitement. He didn't send the patient away. Instead, he went looking for information. He consulted with psychiatrists and a few surgeons around the world who had already performed
事实上，这种手术在全世界都很少进行。唐是一个出人意料的医生人选。据他自己说，他是一个来自中西部的古板男人。但尽管唐最初对性别重置手术的想法退避三舍，他还是感到了一丝兴奋。他没有把病人打发走。相反，他开始寻找信息。他咨询了精神病学家和世界上少数已经做过这种手术的外科医生。
this kind of surgery. What prompted you, this sort of, you know, Catholic doctor from the Midwest, to basically take this on? It seems like an unlikely fit. It was a wonderful opportunity to do a big thing, and to help a lot of people. Altruism and ambition were always tightly woven in Don's identity. He wasn't interested in superficial cosmetic work, he wanted to change the world. He decided to take the leap.
是什么促使你，这个来自中西部的天主教医生，基本上承担起这件事？这似乎是一个不太合适的任务。这是一个做大事并帮助很多人的绝佳机会。利他主义和野心在唐的身份中总是紧密交织在一起。他对表面的美容工作不感兴趣，他想改变世界。他决定迈出这一步。
In November 1968, Don Law performed California's first gender reassignment surgery. We were more than prepared for all the things that might happen. And a surgery went fine. It took about three and a half hours. We did it with the skin graft method, and no problem. Don soon became one of the world's leading experts on gender reassignment surgery. He started a program.
1968年11月，唐·洛布施行了加州首例性别重置手术。我们对可能发生的所有事情做好了充分的准备。手术进行得很顺利。大约花了三个半小时。我们用的是皮瓣移植方法，没有问题。唐很快成为世界领先的性别重置手术专家之一。他启动了一个项目。
His reputation grew. A reputation for being a good surgeon and a tough gatekeeper. He turned away many people because he felt they weren't good candidates for surgery. Sandy still and vividly remembers her first appointment with him in the mid-70s. I go in and sit down and Don is behind his desk and he's wearing his white coat. And he's very distinguished looking and calm and very friendly and open. And he says, well, what can I do for you? And I say the first thing that comes into my head, which is, I think I'm a woman. Now, the scene we have is Don behind his desk and me. I have a long black beard and wild black hair.
他的声誉与日俱增。他以优秀的 surgeons（外科医生）和严厉的守门人著称。他拒绝了许多人，因为他觉得他们不是手术的好人选。桑迪至今仍清晰地记得70年代中期她与他的第一次约会。我走进去坐下，唐坐在他的办公桌后面，穿着他的白大褂。他看起来非常尊贵、冷静、非常友好和开放。他说，嗯，我能为你做点什么？我说出了脑子里浮现的第一件事，那就是，我想我是一个女人。现在，我们眼前的场景是唐坐在办公桌后面，而我留着长长的黑色胡须，有一头狂野的黑发。
I'm wearing a blue shirt, jeans, and engineer's boots. I do not exactly look like I'm thinking of myself as a stereotypical woman. And Don looks at me and says, really? And I say, what should I do? I mean I'm totally, I'm completely open to anything. I really don't know what I should do, what direction I should move in, what's right, what's wrong, and I'm looking to Donald to tell me. And in my memory of the thing Donald then says, well the first thing you should do is there's the beard." That was the beginning of Sandy's long transformative journey. It was a tough
我穿着一件蓝色衬衫、牛仔靴和工程师靴。我看起来绝对不像把自己当成一个刻板印象中的女人。唐看着我说，真的吗？我说，我该怎么办？我的意思是，我对一切都完全开放。我真的不知道我该做什么，我应该朝哪个方向发展，什么是对的，什么是错的，我在指望唐纳德告诉我。在我对那件事的记忆中，唐纳德接着说，嗯，你首先应该做的是，把胡子刮了。那便是桑迪漫长蜕变之旅的开始。那是一段艰难的
journey. Don wanted Sandy to be sure she was making the right decision. So before he would even consider surgery, Sandy says he told her she would have to live openly and fully as a woman for one full year. It was a requirement based on the reality of the time. No one, not Sandy, nor Dawn knew what might come from these surgeries in the long term. These were early days. It was all a bit of an experiment, a shot in the dark. It was fraught. It was fraught for everyone. And it was fraught because at that time it was not clear what would happen later. We didn't have very many examples of transgender people who had had surgery, who went on to
旅程。唐希望桑迪确信她做出了正确的决定。因此，在考虑手术之前，桑迪说他告诉她，她必须作为一个女人公开、完全地生活整整一年。这是一个基于当时现实的要求。没有人，无论是桑迪还是唐，知道从长远来看这些手术会带来什么。那是早期阶段。这一切都有点像是一场实验，黑暗中的一次射击。充满了风险。对每个人来说都充满了风险。而且充满风险是因为当时还不清楚以后会发生什么。我们没有多少做过手术、继续过上充实生活并活着讲述这一切的跨性别者的例子，也就是说，后来回到项目组汇报情况的人很少。
have fulfilling lives and lived to tell about it, which is to say, came back later and reported back to the program. They were experimenting on the fringe of what both medicine and society thought was acceptable. Don was taking risks with his professional reputation. Sandy was taking risks with her life. There was one moment Sandy says when she and Don clashed, the conflict boiled down to their cognitive styles. At some point he asked me if I were a hundred percent committed to wanting surgery. And I said no, I'm not, I'm probably 99.9 percent. I think anyone who is 100% committed to anything is probably crazy. You have to have
他们正在医学和社会的普遍共识边缘进行实验。唐在用他的职业声誉冒着风险。桑迪在用她的生命冒着风险。桑迪说，有一次她和唐发生了冲突，冲突归结为他们的认知风格。在某个时刻，他问我对想要手术是否百分之百投入。我说没有，我不是，我大概是百分之九十九点九。我认为任何对任何事都百分之百投入的人大概都疯了。你在生活中必须
some reservations in life. You have to have an overview of everything that you're doing and have alternative plans if what you're looking for doesn't work out. And Don said, well, in that case, you're not eligible for surgery. You have to be 100% committed. It took a mediated session with Don's assistant for the two of them to resolve the conflict. But the incident revealed something about the way a hedgehog moves through the world. Hedgehogs are decisive. Don could not understand anything less than 100% commitment, even if the 0.1% of doubt was simply a way to say, I'm human. How can I be absolutely sure?
有一些保留。你必须对自己正在做的一切有一个全局的看法，如果你的寻找没有成功，还要有替代计划。唐说，嗯，在这种情况下，你不符合手术的资格。你必须百分之百投入。经过唐的助理介入调解的会议，两人才解决了冲突。但这一事件揭示了刺猬在世界上行动方式的一些特点。刺猬是果断的。唐无法理解任何低于百分之百的投入，即使那0.1%的怀疑只是一种表达我是一个凡人的方式。我怎么能绝对确定呢？
Sandy tells another story of a time she came in for an appointment wearing jeans and a t-shirt. Dawn asked her why she wasn't dressed like a woman. He'd missed the bell-bottom jeans and tie-dye revolution happening right outside his window. It was the kind of thing that could have led to a fight, except for one thing. Sandy understood where Dawn was coming from. She knew that underneath the tough exterior, he really wanted to help, and not just in a medical sense. More than anything, Dawn wanted Sandy to live a life where she didn't feel like an outcast. He wanted his people to be totally remarkable to just fit in to be
桑迪讲了另一件事，有一次她穿着牛仔裤和T恤去预约。唐问她为什么不穿得像个女人。他错过了窗外正在发生的喇叭裤和tie-dye（扎染）革命。这是那种可能导致争端的事情，除了一件事。桑迪理解唐的出发点。她知道在外表冷酷的表象下，他真的很想帮忙，而且不仅仅是在医疗意义上。唐最希望的是桑迪能过上一种不觉得自己是边缘人的生活。他希望他的人能够完全非凡，只是融入其中，能够
able to live their lives to be able to be inconspicuous and just get along and that's a good thing to want for 99% of your waking day is just to be able to live your life, to be able to live with other people and not rub people the wrong way. Sandy Stone successfully underwent surgery in 1977. When I interviewed Sandy, I told her that her story reminded me of another case that Don told me about. It's interesting because I don't first came to my attention because of another case involving cleft lip surgery and it's so striking that as you're saying this I'm sort of hearing
过上自己的生活，能够不引人注目地相处，对于你清醒一天的99%来说，能够过上你的生活，能够和别人一起生活而不惹人生气，这就是一个很好的愿望。桑迪·斯通于1977年成功接受了手术。当我采访桑迪时，我告诉她她的故事让我想起了唐跟我讲的另一个病例。有趣的是，我最初注意到唐是因为另一个涉及唇裂手术的病例，这太引人注目了，当你说这些的时候，我仿佛听到了
echoes of that other work as well. There's a drive that he had to just help people to essentially live what he would think of as being a normal life, a life that they're not ostracized, a life that they're not feeding like they're outcasts, that they're functioning, they can get an education, if they're a child, that they can get a job, if they're an adult, that they can be, that they can be happy. And I feel there's something, something actually very midwestern about that idea. That's the word, that word you said is correct. Don wanted people to be happy. Don did it professionally.
其他那些工作的回声。他有一种驱动力去帮助人们过上他所认为的正常生活，一种不被排挤的生活，一种不觉得自己是边缘人的生活，一种他们能够发挥作用、如果是孩子就能接受教育、如果是成年人就能找到工作、能够快乐的生活。我觉得这其中有某种非常中西部风格的东西。就是这个词，你说的那个词是正确的。唐希望人们快乐。唐是专业地做到这一点的。
His job was to help people to be happy. And for that, I owe him a lifetime debt. I would not have done anything I think that I did after the 1980s, if it weren't for Don Laub, or the 70s, rather, if it weren't for Don Laub. Sandy went on to become a prominent writer and theorist and eventually helped found the academic discipline of transgender studies. When she considers Don's influence on her life, she homes in on his willingness to pursue a big idea with single-minded purpose. Do you go for the big one or do you accept something less?
他的工作就是帮助人们快乐。为此，我欠他一辈子的恩情。如果没有唐·洛布，或者说如果没有70年代的唐·洛布，我绝对不会做我在20世纪80年代之后做的任何事情。桑迪后来成为了一位著名的作家和理论家，并最终帮助创立了跨性别研究这个学术学科。当她思考唐对她生活的影响时，她专注于他愿意以单一的目标去追求一个伟大创意的意愿。你是去追求那个宏大的目标，还是接受一些打折扣的东西？
And many of us accept something less because we don't want to take the risk. And then we may go through life, maybe, maybe we'll be happy with our measure, or maybe we'll say, what if I had gone for what I really wanted? What would that have been like? Maybe I would have died. Yeah, maybe I would have, but I didn't. I beat the odds, and I went on to be glory as I happy. That's something in life.
我们中的许多人接受了打折扣的东西，因为我们不想承担风险。然后我们可能会度过一生，也许，也许我们会对我们的衡量感到满意，或者也许我们会说，如果我去追求我真正想要的东西会怎样？那会是什么样子？也许我会死。是的，也许我会，但我没有。我战胜了命运，我继续走向荣耀和快乐。那是生活中的一件大事。
And Don brought that to many people. I don't see how one could do better than that. Don's leap into the unknown, his willingness to bet his professional reputation on a big idea, his confidence in his own judgment, it had all paid off. The hedgehog had won. But pursuing a big idea with determination doesn't always pay off, and when a hedgehog fails, the fall can be painful. Don Lobb knows about that part of the story too. Stay with us.
唐把这一点带给了许多人。我不认为有人能做得比这更好。唐跃入未知的深渊，他愿意用自己的职业声誉为一个宏大的想法下注，他对自己的判断充满信心，这一切都得到了回报。刺猬赢了。但是，充满决心去追求一个伟大的想法并不总是会有回报，当一只刺猬失败时，痛苦可能是巨大的。唐·洛布也了解故事的那一部分。请继续收听。
knows about that part of the story too. Stay with us. According to the ancient Greek poet Arkelicus, the fox knows many things, but the hedgehog knows one big thing. Psychologists feel tech locks as the metaphor describes two kinds of people. Small picture tacticians are foxes. Big picture strategists are hedgehogs. Before Don Lobb became a world-renowned gender reassignment surgeon, he had another big idea. It started this way. One day a colleague asked him if he could help with the surgery. The patient was a child from Mexico. This was a 14-year-old boy who had no other deformity than his cleft lip and palate.
也了解故事的那一部分。请继续收听。根据古希腊诗人阿基洛科斯的说法，狐狸知道许多事，但刺猬知道一件大事。心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克表示，这个隐喻描述了两种人。注重细节的战术家是狐狸。注重宏观的战略家是刺猬。在唐·洛布成为世界著名的性别重置外科医生之前，他还有另一个宏大的想法。它是这样开始的。有一天，一位同事问他是否能帮忙做一个手术。病人是一个来自墨西哥的孩子。这是一个14岁的男孩，除了唇腭裂之外没有任何其他的畸形。
But because of it, the boy was shunned. A group of priests had driven him north all the way to Stanford to get him help. Don immediately understood that the cleft lip wasn't just a medical problem. He had not gone to school. He had no educational advancement. He had not gone to school, he had no educational advancement, he had no friends. The surgery to repair the cleft lep and pallet was simple and quick. It was so easy and it gave this child a real chance in life. Don says performing the surgery made him feel really good. As someone with deep religious roots
但正因为如此，这个男孩被冷落了。一群神父带着他一路向北来到斯坦福寻求帮助。唐立刻明白，唇裂不仅仅是一个医疗问题。他没有上过学。他没有受过教育。他没有上过学，他没有受过教育，他没有朋友。修复唇腭裂的手术既简单又快速。它是如此简单，并给了这个孩子真正的人生机会。唐说，做这个手术让他感觉非常好。作为一个有着深厚宗教根源
and a Catholic education that emphasized helping the poor, Don felt this was the kind of patient he wanted to serve. He turned to the priest who brought the boy from Mexico. I asked him, are there other patients in Mexico? Like this? They said, the place is full of them. So we bought an airplane ticket and went down to
和强调帮助穷人的天主教教育背景的人，唐觉得这是他想要服务的病人类型。他转向那个把男孩从墨西哥带来的神父。我问他，墨西哥还有其他这样的病人吗？他们说，那个地方到处都是。于是我们买了一张机票，去了
Mexicaly and asked for a clinic. Just like that, where a fox may have calculated the odds, considered the upside and the downside, the hedgehog simply picked up and went. In Mexicali, dawn found a dusty border town in the desert, where the people were very poor. I mean most of the houses were made of packing crates at that time, and there was no paving in Mexicali of 200,000 people. Mexicali's main medical facility was an old wood home.
墨西加利，询问有没有诊所。就这样，狐狸可能会计算几率，权衡利弊，而刺猬则直接收拾行李出发了。在墨西加利，唐发现了一个位于沙漠中的尘土飞扬的边境小镇，那里的人非常穷。我的意思是，当时大多数房子都是用包装箱做的，20万人口的墨西加利没有任何铺砌的道路。墨西加利的主要医疗设施是一栋老木屋。
It had a dirt floor for part of it. The back part of the clinic was used to raise fighting cocks. A rational fox may have calculated the risks and back down, not done. He recruited local health officials to get word out that they would be providing free surgeries for children with cleft lips and burn scars. The clinic was quickly packed. It was 10.30 in the morning.
其中一部分还是泥土地面。诊所的后面部分用来养斗鸡。理性的狐狸可能会计算风险并退缩，但唐没有。他动员当地的卫生官员散布消息，他们将为患有唇裂和烧伤疤痕的儿童提供免费手术。诊所很快就挤满了人。那是上午十点半。
In that desert, there had not been rain there for three years. The hot in the morning was about 106 degrees already. You couldn't touch anything metal because you burned your hand. The first patient I saw was sitting there with the bag. I just had two little peep holes. I said, what's with the, why the bag? Behind those peep holes, the boy was hiding his face in shame. Don asked if he could take a look.
在那个沙漠里，已经三年没下过雨了。早上的高温已经达到了106华氏度（约41摄氏度）左右。你不能碰任何金属东西，因为你会烫伤手。我看到的第一个病人坐在那里拿着个袋子。我只是有两个小窥孔。我说，这是怎么回事，为什么要用袋子？在那些窥孔后面，那个男孩正满脸羞耻地藏起他的脸。唐问他是否可以看一看。
So he got the bag off, and he had a burn scar to pull this island down. A simple thing to repair. As with Sandy, Don wanted to make the little boy, undremarkable. He wanted him to lead an ordinary life, unmarked by stigma and shame. That first trip was just a fact-finding mission, a way to see if there was a need. By the time Don went back to Stanford, a plan had formed in his mind. He wanted to recruit the best doctors from the United States and fly them to Mexico to perform free surgeries on children with birth defects. He recruited surgical residents to join skilled surgeons on the trips. He found pilots willing to transport medical equipment.
于是他把袋子拿下来，他有一个把眼睑往下拉的烧伤疤痕。修复起来很简单。就像对待桑迪一样，唐想让这个小男孩变得不引人注目。他希望他能过上普通的生活，没有耻辱和羞耻的烙印。第一次旅行只是一次事实调查任务，一种看看是否有需求的方式。当唐回到斯坦福时，一个计划在他心中形成了。他想招募美国最好的医生，把他们飞到墨西哥，为有先天缺陷的儿童进行免费手术。他招募了外科住院医师和熟练的外科医生一起参加这些旅行。他找到了愿意运送医疗设备的飞行员。
Hejogs have charisma. They can see the shining city on the hill so clearly that everyone around them starts to see it too. Everybody jumped on it. the hill so clearly that everyone around them starts to see it too. In 1966, the official medical missions began. Now it's important to remember that at this time, the idea of plastic surgeons going abroad to provide free surgery was almost unheard of. There were fewer parameters of how international aid organizations should operate. Don was flying by the seat of his pants. Every few months the doctors would descend on Mexicali.
刺猬具有个人魅力。他们能如此清晰地看到山巅之城，以至于他们身边的每个人也开始看到它。每个人都对此跃跃欲试。山巅之城如此清晰地呈现在眼前，以至于周围的每个人也开始看到了。1966年，官方的医疗任务开始了。现在重要的是要记住，在当时，整形外科医生出国提供免费手术的想法几乎闻所未闻。国际援助组织应该如何运作的参数更少。唐是在摸着石头过河。每隔几个月，医生们就会降落在墨西加利。
They'd throw themselves into four marathon days of back-to-back surgeries and consultations. Over the years they'd come back, again and again, performing more than 2,000 surgeries in all. One of Don's first patients was a little boy named Eugeneio. He was the boy who'd worn the bag over his head. Don repaired the scarred eyelid, and still remembers the boy's first reaction. He had a very nice, huge smile. On a follow-up trip, Don tracked Eugene you down. He shook hands and everything like that, even as a young kid. And he said,
他们投入到连续四天高强度的马拉松式手术和会诊中。多年来，他们一次又一次地回来，总共进行了2000多台手术。唐最早的病人之一是一个叫尤金尼奥的小男孩。他就是那个头上套着袋子的男孩。唐修复了有疤痕的眼睑，并且仍然记得这个男孩的第一次反应。他露出了非常 nice（友好）、巨大的微笑。在随后的回访中，唐找到了尤金尼奥。他甚至作为一个小孩子就握手诸如此类的。他说，
I have friends at school, no. Don loved it. He's a real happiness. It's a source of happiness. It's the best description. If anything, Don and that I would describe it as a very, and I think he would accept it, I think it was a very sort of a missionary zeal. This is plastic surgeon Howard Holdeness. He was part of the team of residents helping perform surgeries in Mexicali. Howard says that Don's vision drove the whole team. I think he felt very close to trying to do things that not only practiced medicine and all of its forms of science and everything, but the art of medicine and some of the spiritual
我在学校有朋友了，不。唐很喜欢。这真的是一种快乐。这是快乐的源泉。这是最好的描述。如果有的话，唐和我都会将其描述为一种，而且我认为他会接受这一点，我认为这是一种非常类似于传教士的热忱。这是整形外科医生霍华德·霍尔德尼斯。他是帮助在墨西加利进行手术的住院医师团队的一员。霍华德说，唐的愿景推动了整个团队。我觉得他非常接近于尝试做这样的事情，不仅实践医学及其所有的科学形式和一切，还有医学的艺术以及作为一个好医生的某些精神
aspects of being a good doctor. He was doing more than surgeries. Don was developing a program that could set an example for others to follow around the world. One day about two years into the Mexico program, a woman arrived at the clinic with her young son. His name was Salvador. Compared with the other patients, Salvador had a more severe birth defect.
层面。他做的不仅仅是手术。唐正在开发一个可以为世界各地其他人树立榜样的项目。在墨西哥项目进行了大约两年后的某一天，一位妇女带着她的小儿子来到了诊所。他的名字叫萨尔瓦多。与其他患者相比，萨尔瓦多有更严重的先天缺陷。
He had bilateral clets, clefts rather than one. When you have this bilateral, the muscles are cut twice. So, when you smile, they pull out. If they're repaired, they pull in. See? So, every time he would have a facial expression, it would be awful. You'd see these teeth on both sides. Salvador was a perfect candidate for surgery.
他有双侧裂，而不是单侧裂。当你出现这种双侧裂时，肌肉被切了两次。所以，当你微笑时，它们会向外拉扯。如果修复了，它们就会向内拉。明白吗？所以，他每次做面部表情时，都会变得很糟糕。你会看到两侧的牙齿。萨尔瓦多是手术的完美人选。
That is, until a doctor on the team gave the boy a thorough physical and listened to his heart with a stethoscope. His mother brought him in and the pediatrician listened and he was, whoosh, whoosh, whoosh, the heart sounds. These were not normal sounds. The boy's heart had a hole in it. The risk of proceeding with surgery was small, but potentially fatal. They gave the mother the bad news.
也就是说，直到团队中的一名医生对男孩进行了全面的身体检查，并用听诊器听了他的心脏。他的母亲把他带了进来，儿科医生听了听，然后是，呼，呼，呼，心音。这些不是正常的声音。男孩的心脏有一个洞。继续手术的风险很小，但可能是致命的。他们把这个坏消息告诉了母亲。
We can't operate because we don't have the equipment in Mexico, do the hard catheterization or anything like that or any, even get the E.K.G. today. So Dawn and his team turned away the mother and the little boy. I should say here that we're going only on Dawn's account of what happened, the medical records from that ERR incomplete and we weren't able to find the mother. A few months after sending the child away, Dawn and his team were back in Mexico. The mother and her son were waiting for them again.
我们不能做手术，因为我们在墨西哥没有设备来做心脏导管插入术之类的东西，甚至连今天的心电图都做不了。于是唐和他的团队拒绝了这位母亲和小男孩。我在这里应该说明，我们完全根据唐对所发生事情的叙述，那里的病历不完整，我们没能找到这位母亲。把孩子送走几个月后，唐和他的团队又回到了墨西哥。母亲和她的儿子又在等他们了。
Salvador, she told them, was shunned. He had no friends. Other children called him El Monstre. The monster. The mother said, this child has no chance in life. You got to fix it. Don's heart went out to the little boy. He explained the danger again. The risk was small, but it did mean that things could go seriously wrong. Don held the stethoscope up to the mother's ears.
萨尔瓦多，她告诉他们，被排挤了。他没有朋友。别的孩子叫他“El Monstre”。怪物。母亲说，这个孩子在生活中没有机会。你必须修复它。唐对这个小男孩充满了同情。他再次解释了危险。风险很小，但这确实意味着事情可能会严重出错。唐把听诊器拿给母亲的耳朵。
Listen, she can hear it, whoosh, whoosh, whoosh. So the answer again was no. More months passed. Don returned to the clinic, so did the mother. Poor for war. Please, doctor. Can you see the child has no life? This was a critical moment. Don could again have said no.
听听，她能听到，呼，呼，呼。所以答案依然是否定的。几个月过去了。唐回到了诊所，母亲也回来了。穷困潦倒。求求你，医生。你能看到这个孩子没有生活吗？这是一个关键时刻。唐本可以再次拒绝。
Medical protocol said that was the right call. But Don also knew that without surgery, Salvador would always be an outcast. Could he have tried to take the boy back to Stanford where hot surgeons could have assisted with his care? Maybe. But that would have been complicated, expensive, and a drain on critical resources from the project in Mexico,
医疗规程说那是正确的决定。但唐也知道，如果没有手术，萨尔瓦多将永远是一个局外人。他本可以尝试把男孩带回斯坦福，那里的顶尖外科医生可以协助他的护理吗？也许吧。但这将是复杂的、昂贵的，并且会消耗墨西哥项目中的关键资源，
resources that were helping hundreds of other children. So Don did what Don always did. He took a look at the child, took a deep breath and said, okay, we'll do it. I feel like that's why I existed. Is for this judgment. I mean, I'm not there to take care of little pimples. I'm there to do the tough cases. So this was putting it right on the line.
这些资源正在帮助数百名其他儿童。所以唐做了唐一贯会做的事。他看了看孩子，深吸了一口气，说，好吧，我们来做。我觉得这就是我存在的意义。就是为了这个判断。我的意思是，我不是去照顾小粉刺的。我是来处理疑难杂症的。所以这是把一切都押在上面了。
You got to do it or put your tail between your legs and get out of there. It's been nearly 50 years since Don Law performed that surgery on a six-year-old boy in Mexicali, Mexico. He's had thousands of patients since then, but the details of that day are still vivid in his mind. The morning of the surgery, the boy went through the standard pre-surgery lap test and check-up, and
你必须这样做，否则就夹着尾巴滚蛋。自从唐·洛布在墨西哥墨西加利为那个六岁男孩做那台手术以来，已经过去了将近50年。从那以后他有了成千上万的患者，但那一天的细节在他的脑海中依然清晰。手术那天早上，男孩通过了标准的术前实验室测试和检查，
Ivy was started, and he received extra glucose in case his blood sugar was low from stomach worms, and then the boy walked by himself into the operating room. And he gets an anaphyring table himself. Because he trusts the operating room. And he gets on the operating table himself. Because he trusts the whole world. The surgery began. First, the child was anesthetized. So that went fine. When perfect, no problem at all. Then Dawn and his team began the surgery. When we were operating, everything was going perfect. And then, just like that, it wasn't. And I see jealous and boys.
静脉注射开始了，他获得了额外的葡萄糖，以防他的血糖因为胃里的寄生虫而降低，然后男孩自己走进了手术室。他自己上了麻醉台。因为他信任手术室。他自己爬上了手术台。因为他信任整个世界。手术开始了。首先，对孩子进行麻醉。所以进展得很顺利。非常完美，一点问题也没有。然后唐和他的团队开始手术。当我们进行手术时，一切都进行得非常完美。然后，就在那一刻，不再完美了。我看到了嫉妒和男孩。（注：此处原文“jealous and boys”可能为语音识别错误或特定医疗术语的谐音误写，译文保留字面）
We have no pulse. They tried everything. CPR, medicine to jumpstart the heart, nothing worked. Don suspected a blood clot. The boy was dead. They put away their surgical tools. They wheeled the body to the morgue. All the while, Dan's heart was starting to race. He was working in a foreign country, and he had made a risky judgment call in violation of medical protocol. And my mind is going a thousand miles an minute. Why am I here in Mexico? Why did I get into this? What the hell is the matter with you? Here you are in a foreign country.
我们没有脉搏了。他们尝试了一切。心肺复苏，用于重启心脏的药物，什么都不起作用。唐怀疑是血栓。男孩死了。他们收起手术工具。他们把尸体推到了太平间。与此同时，丹的心开始狂跳。他在一个外国工作，他做出了违反医疗规程的冒险判断。我的大脑在一分钟内转了一千英里。我为什么在墨西哥？我为什么要卷入这档子事？你到底有什么毛病？你现在在一个外国。
You can end up in jail. It's just a goddamn disaster. An awful thing. And of course, there God damn disaster! An awful thing! And of course, there was the boy's mother, waiting anxiously outside for news of her son. Don remembers stepping out of the operating room and walking up to her. He told her they'd been complications that they had tried hard, but the boy had died. The mother began to sob, but then Don says, she did something surprising. She asked him why he was upset. She said, you should be happy because the child is seeing God with a complete face. Don had expected accusation and anger.
你最终可能会进监狱。这简直就是该死的灾难。一件可怕的事。当然，还有男孩的母亲，在外面焦急地等待着她儿子的消息。唐记得自己走出手术室向她走去。他告诉她，出现了并发症，他们已经尽力了，但男孩已经死了。母亲开始抽泣，但接着唐说，她做了一件令人惊讶的事。她问他为什么这么难过。她说，你应该高兴，因为孩子带着完整的面容去见上帝了。唐本以为会受到指责和愤怒。
Instead he encountered a mother who leaned heavily on her faith. Don said she was comforted by the thought that her child was now repaired and beautiful and at home with God. Salvador was finally at peace. Don stayed at the mother. He was speechless, not just because of what she said, but because he was struck by another thought. The mother didn't know this, but Salvador's face was not repaired. He died before the surgery was complete. What would the mother say when she saw her son at the funeral? Again, the medical protocol was clear. Don had to turn the body over to Salvador's mother. But he felt he couldn't bring himself to do this. It would only compound the first tragedy. He conferred with his team about finishing the surgery
相反，他遇到了一位极度依赖信仰的母亲。唐说，她被这样的想法安慰了：她的孩子现在已经修好了，很漂亮，在上帝的家里。萨尔瓦多终于平静了。唐呆呆地看着母亲。他无言以对，不仅仅是因为她说了什么，还因为他被另一个想法击中了。母亲不知道这一点，但萨尔瓦多的脸并没有修复。他在手术完成前就死了。母亲在葬礼上看到儿子时会说些什么？同样，医疗规程很明确。唐必须把遗体交还给萨尔瓦多的母亲。但他觉得自己做不到这一点。那只会让第一场悲剧雪上加霜。他与团队商讨完成对萨尔瓦多的手术
on Salvador. I said it's against the law, but I think in this case we should. The rest of the team unanimously agreed. The little boy was brought back from the morgue. The child came back on a body bag, and we did the whole thing as if the child was awake. I interviewed Don several times for the story. I pushed hard to understand why he decided to operate on Salvador. What were you telling yourself, again, emotionally, that made you change your mind, that made you say, yes, I recognize this is a risk, but I have to do this. I thought this is what I, what I am for. This is my purpose. And you said it's worth it standing there and I couldn't say no again. I didn't I couldn't. But I made it to see what I said that. Let's go ahead and do the case.
我说这违反法律，但我认为在这种情况下我们应该这样做。团队的其他成员一致同意。小男孩被从太平间带了回来。孩子被装在裹尸袋里送了回来，我们就像孩子还醒着一样完成了整个过程。我为这个故事采访了唐好几次。我极力追问，想了解他为什么决定给萨尔瓦多做手术。你到底在对自己说什么，从情感上讲，是什么让你改变了主意，让你说，是的，我认识到这是一个风险，但我必须这么做。我想这就是我，我存在的意义。这是我的目的。你说站在那里是值得的，我不能再拒绝了。我没有，我不能。但我还是决定把这个病例做下去。
I didn't have any second thoughts. Emotionally I figured out that this is what I should do. Don still thinks about Salvador has thought about him thousands of times over the years. He's turned the case over in his head in every possible way. I asked him over and over whether he felt regret. No. Well, of course I do. Of course I do. Of course I do.
我没有任何二心。从情感上讲，我弄清楚了这就是我应该做的。唐依然在想着萨尔瓦多，这些年来已经想过成千上万次了。他在脑海中以各种可能的方式翻来覆去地琢磨这个病例。我一次又一次地问他是否感到后悔。没有。嗯，我当然有。我当然有。我当然有。
Yes, I do. I mean, you said just a minute ago, it was a mistake. But I don't have, I don't, I don't, I'm not whipping myself. Not whipping himself, Don says, because he was trying to do the right thing. That's the reason he decided to operate. That's the reason he completed the surgery after the child was dead.
是的，我有。我的意思是，你刚才还说，这是一个错误。但我没有，我没有，我没有，我没有在鞭笞自己。没有鞭笞自己，唐说，因为他是在试图做正确的事。这就是他决定做手术的原因。这就是他在孩子死后完成手术的原因。
What was more important than being on the right side of the law? Doing the right thing. By the mother and by the child. Yes, yeah. No, you must always do the right thing. That is the highest priority over all different laws and commandments or any of that thing. You have to do the right thing. The day after Salvador died, Don Lab was back in the operating room. There were more children
有什么比站在法律正确的一边更重要？做正确的事。对母亲而言，对孩子而言。是的，是的。不，你必须永远做正确的事。那是高于所有不同法律、诫命或任何类似事情的最高优先级。你必须做正确的事。萨尔瓦多死后的第二天，唐·洛布又回到了手术室。还有更多的孩子
waiting for surgery. He remembers looking out the windows of the sky, it was, he says, a perfect, asuar blue. At 10.30 the time when Salvador was to be buried, everyone on the team felt silent and paused. There was no sound except for the whoosh of the Anasthesia machine. When we think of foxes and hedgehogs, it's completely understandable that we want the best of both worlds. We love bold visionaries who take big risks, except when the risks don't work. At moments like that, we prefer the visionaries to be more cautious,
在等待手术。他记得望着窗外的天空，那是，他说，一种完美的天青蓝色。在上午十点半，也就是萨尔瓦多本该下葬的时间，团队中的每个人都陷入了沉默并停了下来。除了麻醉机的呼呼声外，没有任何声音。当我们想到狐狸和刺猬时，我们想要两全其美是完全可以理解的。我们喜欢承担巨大风险的大胆梦想家，除非风险没有奏效。在这样的时刻，我们更希望梦想家能够更谨慎，
filled with a little self-doubt. Now people don't always fall neatly into one camp or the other. Some of us can be both Fox and Hedgehog, we can think and dream big, but also change course, adapt to circumstances. But it may be that we can't have our cake and eat it too. If we want the visionary Steve Jobs who helped usher in the age of the iPhone, we might also get the tyrannical CEO who nearly ran Apple computers into the ground in the 1980s. It's odd to think of Gandhi and Napoleon and Churchill and Mao in the same breath, but
充满一些自我怀疑。现在人们并不总是整齐地落入一个阵营或另一个阵营。我们有些人既可以成为狐狸，也可以成为刺猬，我们可以有宏大的思考和梦想，但也可以改变路线，适应环境。但可能我们无法鱼与熊掌兼得。如果我们想要帮助开启iPhone时代的富有远见的史蒂夫·乔布斯，我们可能也会得到那个在20世纪80年代差点把苹果电脑搞垮的暴君CEO。把甘地、拿破仑、丘吉尔和毛泽东放在一起相提并论，这听起来很奇怪
they are cut from the same cloth of Messianic vision. It's easy not to like the kind of people who create history's greatest failures, but it turns out they're also the people who produce our greatest triumphs. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Maggie Penman, René Clarre and René Cohen. The music in today's show was composed by Rampti and Arab Louis. Our unsung hero this week is another hedgehog and another Don. Donal Drake was a colleague and friend of mine at the Philadelphia
它们都源于同一种救世主般的愿景。人们很容易讨厌那些创造历史最大失败的人，但事实证明，他们也是创造我们最伟大胜利的人。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队包括麦琪·彭曼、雷内·克拉尔和雷内·科恩。今天节目的音乐由拉姆蒂和阿拉b·路易斯创作。我们本周的无名英雄是另一只刺猬和另一位唐。唐纳尔·德雷克曾是我的同事和朋友，在费城
in Quarra many years ago. He taught me many things about writing and storytelling. We even wrote a play together. Don's in poor health right now in Philadelphia, and I wanted to give him a shout out for all that he's done for me. Thanks, Don. For more hidden brain,
多年前在夸拉。他教会了我许多关于写作和讲故事的知识。我们甚至一起写过一部剧本。唐现在费城身体状况不佳，我想对他在我身上所做的一切表示感谢。谢谢你，唐。欲了解更多Hidden Brain内容，
you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedanthantham, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并在当地公共广播电台收听我的故事。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔纳特姆，这里是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。